if anyone knew the truth of my life
they'd be shocked Oh a month ago is what
you think killing time between gigs in
my podcast but then something went down
that changed things forever I was
keeping it buried until I met Fred will
aid at our favorite diner Prince not the
simple balloony place so brilliantly you
know something was amiss why the longer
face unusual Fred what your face is
hanging in your soup I could trust you
right come on we friends have a bond all
right listen to some of my messages you
son of a not calling me back you
disrespectful okay with interest
you owe me three hundred thousand now
and if you so much as think of going to
the feds or to the cops tearing your
limbs off and beating you to death with
them will seem like a blow job and limbo
compared to what I will do to
you huh what's going on you know my book
yeah yeah nice breezy read
though I didn't read the whole thing I
just skimmed to the stuff about me well
I should have read the contract more
closely I had to pay for the book tour
and all the staples that held it
together the staples ad up my credit
wasn't good so I borrowed from the sky
who hangs out at the comedy club I
didn't know he's in the mob interest is
crazy my god this is the crazy stuff you
only hear about on podcast radio serials
oh no it's him again I'll take that
listen you I'm Fred Willard renowned
actor and you gotta give Fred sometime
he'll get some big gigs someday and pay
you back I mean look at his track record
that might not be such a good idea don't
don't look at the track record all right
listen to me you renowned actor
your end is now too you'll both do my
dirty work if you want to live why don't
we all just calm down i can give you
something to sell on ebay a sign Best in
Show DVD yeah it'll it'll get up.get
it'll fetch about 40 bucks Brad wasn't
able its draw me out of my mess I had a
work to make my vid I was meeting Marco
at the hell I doubt the back of dolly
strip club
there were all kinds of scary guys with
names like murder scar scan and Martin
okay you'll need a block ski mask some
papers a gun I don't know how to use it
and look for scar a guy named that
because of the one going across his face
didn't like the idea of me having a gun
either why don't you watch a tutorial on
youtube you hemorrhoid Marco I don't
want to this clown run with us we going
to chinese pool hall with chachi he'll
panic and shooting the Allard get us all
killed Chinese pulivaal what's going on
the termites had the nerve to rob our
big pokey game we lost two good men
along with our tilt don't worry scar
we'll just have a man the back door in
case of any stragglers come in the junk
come on I don't like this I don't like
this either so this will be my first job
in my obligation no second second yep
you gotta dispose of Vinny Rosetti we
put him in the trunk of your car where
where do I put him hey that's your
headache up and have them trace
back to us your head will be more than
18 so I was instructed how we raid the
Chinese pole vault but first I had a
call sort of bullet in its head I had a
deal with so I called fred-bag hey Fred
you shake those goons no no it's a
matter of fact that you were dead body
in my car I have to dispose up can I
bury him in your yard there's so much
space there I don't think that's a good
idea my wife has the flowers arranged
perfectly spelling out my name
what's the neighbors dogs always digging
in there okay guess I'll figure this out
on my own man maybe don't throw it out I
use it for car pools or as an ironing
board people know me as the neurotic
nebbish but when your backs to the wall
you do what you gotta do in that old
fart I had to get my life back so me
scar scab Marty murderer and Johnny tank
approach to speakeasy in Chinatown no
white face had ever seen the insides of
Tanks pool hall and live to talk about
it but I had an idea my friend Jimmy
owyang scored as the chinese tech guy
Silicon Valley I had to meet a spider
joint yeah Freddie what's up man where
you want to eat wait where are these
guys it's a long story but we need to go
in the pee hole we need you to talk to
the door guy maybe get him to let us in
say something what we think us all
Chinese guys are connected or we have
like a special word we all know and we
say to each other super racist it oh
yeah I have a dream speech just try to
get the door open but Jimmy owed me we
had a deal every time I bought a chick I
was too old cool I brought a Jimmy's way
nothing ever turned out from that but
still
hey I thought oh i wanta wiping out I am
I on want him da review time that's
right I am oh okay no I got my I mean
the good instead to decide scarf poked
his gun in my ribs have been patient
what's going on Jimmy this is amazing
he's my cousin and he's not a lot of
said the door opened the next thing Jim
Ian and his cousin saw was our ski masks
on the next thing they saw was the butt
of scars gun to the back of the cousins
head knocking him out what the
don't know my cousin scar then did the
same thing to Jimmy what the you
doing my friend Jimmy you'll be safer
staying here so you rushed down the
steps of guns out
put your hands up William sin and don't
screen into that I don't speak English
scar and murder grabbed all the
cash on the table while me tank and
Marty kept the guns locked on them I was
scared but not as scared as I thought
I'd be I had seen this in someone he
flicks it didn't seem real I was ok till
scar seemed to push it on the
safe have them open it sad sack keep the
gun on him I am it's on him second seem
forever I wanted a today more than
anything I was ok to one of them reached
under the table and
there was a cloud of smoke I shot back
as I ran out I didn't see if I hit
anyone but then I look back into our
Asian bodies on the floor tank was hit
scar helped him get up the stairs he was
hit in the shoulder and from what I've
seen on TV I knew that wasn't
life-threatening but he sure as
didn't look good we came upon Jimmy and
his cousin still knocked down Marty
raised his gun and blew a hole of the
guy's head waking up Jimmy he then put
the gun to Jimmy said no you do not do
that he knows too much in a move I never
imagined I put a gun to him the mess I
made sure as wasn't gonna get her
friend killed you up big time
chachi scar put his gun on me we were in
a Mexican standoff
when we heard the sirens we knew we had
to settle this later we put our guns
down and scooted down the alley to our
getaway car he's bleeding what happened
man this is a brand-new car can you hold
him out the window I felt bad willits
car would need an expensive cleaning but
Marco said will it only needed to do
that one deed could have been worse for
him but we still had to get out of there
we piled in this guy can drive you sure
I just drive you take too long I am
going I'll give you a five-minute window
you do what you got to do after that I
am gone we drove like a demon he was
kicking ass and I was impressed you
driven get away before no that's the
monologue from dr i haven't memorized
with a long shot but my agent you got me
in damn I never get to do a gritty drama
tell me about it you look so much better
than ryan gosling it's it's almost worth
getting killed to meet you sir we
stopped my dollies the crew clean
willits car marker let him go will it
was free thanks Marco I mean can't you
let Fred go to he was pretty amazing
back there yeah you better not push it
any warm body can hold the gun he's far
from being off
and so I was sometimes employed
character actor looking for work undead
it to the mob waiting for my next
obligation which came in a voicemail the
next day oh I killed the little chinese
guy he knows too much